The original run of Twin Peaks is something
that feels entirely unique to me.
Even decades later, after countless other
shows have been influenced by or ripped off
various elements of Twin Peaks, there’s
something there that nobody has recreated
in quite the same way David Lynch and Mark
Frost managed to in the early 90’s.
When I heard that Twin Peaks was returning,
I was excited and intrigued, and a little
worried.
What would the return of Twin Peaks look like?
Are the things that Lynch and Frost care about
and want to continue on the same things that
fans of the show care about?
And as Twin Peaks: The Return unfolds, I think
we can begin to answer that question.
I’m Thomas Flight.
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video.
This video will contain images from all seasons
of Twin Peaks, but I’ll try to avoid major
plot spoilers.
Twin Peaks is a difficult show to talk about,
it’s hard to describe to people, and I find
it difficult to explain what it is I like
about the show.
But there’s a word that seems to come up
again and again.
Weird.
Twin Peaks is weird.
I don’t mean that in a negative sense.
It’s weirdness catches you off guard.
Much of it has a conventional facade laden
with soap opera tropes and drama, but as it
pulls you into what feels like normalcy, it
uncovers it’s strange underbelly.
Part of what I think created the unique magic
of the original seasons was David Lynch’s
weirdness constrained by the necessity of
creating a network TV show.
Lynch’s films are something amazing to experience,
and I enjoy when a director has free reign
over a project to do what they want.
But sometimes something very interesting can
come out of a situation that puts constraint
on an artist.
David Lynch had to make a TV show that the
network would allow him to air, the result
is a well made crime drama with a subtle foundation
of Lynch’s stylistic weirdness, while occasionally
the full force of his brand of weird breaks
through, creating the strangest tv show on
the air at the time.
This brings us back to Twin Peaks The Return.
As I watched the first several episodes of
the new season, I often found myself wondering,
what is Twin Peaks to David Lynch?
In the new season, Lynch is unconstrained,
and some of the vibe that constituted what
I personally felt was “Twin Peaks” was
lost.
If the old show was 70% Network tv and 30%
full blown Lynch, the new season was 30% my
idea of Twin Peaks and 70% full blown Lynch.
Don’t get me wrong, as a fan of what I’m
calling “full blown David Lynch” I was
excited to be watching something different
and experimental.
I might be missing a little of the campy,
soap opera vibe of the original seasons, but
I was excited to be watching Lynch do his
thing.
Then I watched episode 8.
I sat there, somewhat astounded that Showtime
actually allowed Lynch to air this on TV.
And it hit me…
This is Twin Peaks.
David Lynch wasn’t creating a new season
that would just give me more of the feelings
I have watching a 25 year old, campy and quirky
tv show.
Whether it was his intention or not he was
creating a show that would give even a seasoned
viewer of modern TV the sort of experience
people had watching the original Twin Peaks
air.
The original run of Twin Peaks was on after
shows like Cheers, viewers must have been
struck by the unique strangeness, some would
have asked “what the heck am I watching?”
But watching the original seasons of twin
peaks now doesn’t give you quite that experience,
you can still feel it’s weirdness years
later, but we’re so surrounded by other
shows that have similar levels of weirdness
in them, that the original weirdness of twin
peaks doesn’t stand in as stark contrast
to everything around it anymore.
But Twin Peaks, is once again with it’s
return, decades later, probably the strangest
thing to ever air on TV.
David Lynch continues to push the boundaries,
to tell stories how he wants to tell them,
not how they should be told.
I don’t want to be reductive.
I’m not saying twin peaks is only “Weird”
or that it only pushes boundaries.
But when I was anticipating the new season,
pushing the boundaries of storytelling is
an element of the show that I had overlooked
in my anticipation about being reunited with
old characters and old storylines being concluded.
And I don’t think Lynch’s goal is simply
to be weird either, in Twin Peaks a significant
theme is characters encountering things that
are or appear otherworldly.
An important aspect of telling a story about
how people behave in the face of things they
don’t understand is creating at least some
of those feelings within
the audience.
This will inevitably turn some people away.
I’m sure there may have been a drop in viewership
of the new season after episode 8, just as
viewership of the original seasons dropped
off.
But if Twin Peaks was accessible, it may arguably
not be the same twin peaks.
And as I go back over episodes of the new
season I’m seeing many of the ingredients
that made up the original Twin Peaks are present.
Even if a lot of the plot takes place away
from the beloved little town, you can see
almost every element of what would make up
Twin Peaks the return watching the original
seasons.
And I’ve come to realize that the weirdness
of Twin Peaks isn’t just a sideshow, it’s
fundamental to the experience.
Twin Peaks The Return is a genre defying show
that plays the spectrum from goofy humor to
genuine psychological horror.
And it expands on the world of Twin Peaks
in unpredictable and fascinating ways.
The original twin peaks was a singular, interesting,
influential creation.
And I firmly believe that Twin Peaks: The
Return is as well.
Thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video.
When I started out making websites there were
5 or more different skills you had to learn,
and a many tools you had to use just to get
up and running.
Now if someone wants a website I just recommend
squarespace to them.
Squarespace is an all in one platform, so
you have everything you need to have a website,
including a domain name.
You just pick one of the beautiful award-winning
templates, customize it to your needs, and
you’re ready to go.
If you have an idea or project you want to
get started on, get the ball rolling and make
your next move with squarespace.
Start your free trial today, at Squarespace.com
and enter offer code THOMASFLIGHT to get 10%
off your first purchase.